حزب يمثل الجناح المحافظ المعتدل في تركيا
حقق مكانه متميزه في تاريخ الجمهوريه
السياسي يعلن احترام الحريات الدينيه
والفكريات المختلفه ويؤكد عدم معارضته
للعلمانيه والمبادئ التي قامت عليها
الجمهوريه حزب العداله والتنميه
ازمه
اكثر تنين
ضاق الشعب بها درعا في فتره ثلاث انقلابا
ابيض على الزعيم نجم الدين اربكان عام
فاكد اردوغان في اول خطاب له بعد توليه
الزعامه ان ميلاد حزبه سيكون بدايه لارساء
مفهوم العقل التشاوري يمكن للمواطنين من
خلاله محاسبه المسؤولين بشفافيه وموضوعيه
[موسيقى]
اسس الحزب نواب كانوا يمثلون جناح
المجددين في حزب الفضيله الاسلامي الذي حل
بقرار صدر من المحكمه الدستوريه في الثاني
والعشرين من يونيو حزيران 2001 واتخذ من
المصباح المضيء رمزا له في اشاره الى
الشفافيه في الاداره في حين يرمز لونه
الاصفر الى الحيويه والمعرفه والحكمه
والقوه بدات تجربه الحزب الانتخابيه في
الثالث من نوفمبر تشرين الثاني عام 2002
فاظهر تفوقا على جميع التيارات السياسيه
الموجوده في الساحه انذاك بعد ان فاز
باربعه وثلاثين بالمئه من الاصوات وحصد
363 مقعدا في البرلمان لتتوالى بعد
انتصارات انتخابيه نحو عقدين مثلت
الانتخابات المحليه في عام 2004 اختبارا
مهما للحزب اذ كانت اول انتخابات تجرى بعد
توليه السلطه
احرز المركز الاول بنسبه 42% من اصوات
الناخبين واعاد تاكيد نجاحه في الانتخابات
التشريعيه عام 2007 وهو العام نفسه الذي
فاز فيه عبد الله جول مرشح الحزب بالرئاسه
خلفا لسلفه احمد نجده سيزار بعد ان حصل
على اصوات
339 نائبا من اجمالي اصوات 500 وخمسين
نائبا في البرلمان في عام 2010 احتفل
الحزب بفوزه في الاستفتاء في التعديلات
الدستوريه واحرز فوزا كبيرا في الانتخابات
التشريعيه عام 2011 وفي اول انتخابات
اجريت بالاقتراع المباشر عام 2014
نجح اردوغان في حسم الفوز من الجوله
الاولى وما هو سوى عام واحد فقط وتحديدا
في الثامن عشر من يونيو حزيران 2015 اجرت
تركيا انتخابات برلمانيه شهد فيها حزب
العداله
بعد ان حصل على اربعين بالمئه من الاصوات
و 288 مقعدا في البرلمان واخفق في تشكيل
حكومه ائتلافيه مع احزاب سياسيه اخرى
واخفقت احزاب المعارضه ايضا في تشكيل
حكومه ائتلافيه فيما بينها فدعى الرئيس
اردوغان الى انتخابات مبكره بعد بضعه اشهر
حصل فيها الحزب على المركز الاول بنسبه
49%
و316 مقعدا
يؤكد الحزب في مبادئه فكره الحفاظ على
وحده الامه التركيه وذلك بحمايه التنوع
الديني والثقافي للمواطنين ورفض اشكال
التمييز وانه يسعى الاحترام الحقوق
الفكريه والسياسيه للمواطنين في اطار نظام
ديمقراطي يحترم حريه التعبير فاطلق عام
2002 وعدا تعهد فيه باثاره قضيه الحجاب
والعمل على رفع الحظر عنه فور وصوله الى
السلطه لكنه لم يتمكن من اتخاذ خطوات
فعليه في البدايه الى ان اطلق عام 2013
حزمه من التعديلات الجديده شملت حريه
ارتداء الحجاب وحقوق الاقليات وسمحت
للمحجبات بالعمل في مؤسسات الدوله وفي عام
2016 سمح لهن بالعمل في الجيش والشرطه
والاجهزه الامنيه خارجيا يتبنى سياسه
تمكين تركيا دوله اقليميه فاعله
هو ما دفعه الى تبني سياسه صفر مشكلات مع
جميع الدول الاقليميه والجوار لكن مع
اندلاع الثورات الربيع العربي عام 2011
بدا الحزب يتخذ نهجا اكثر ديناميكيه
فاستقبل الملايين من اللاجئين في اراضيه
ودخلت تركيا مرحله من التحولات والتبدلات
في علاقاتها الدوليه اما على المستوى
الاقتصادي فتتسم تجربه الحزب بالايجابيه
والتطور منذ تولي السلطه عام 2002 فقد
حققت تركيا في عهده الكثير من الانجازات
في مشروعات كبرى ولا سيما في التجاره
الخارجيه اذ وصلت الصادرات السلعيه نموها
باستمرار على الرغم من المشكلات التي
واجهتها البلاد مثل ارتفاع سعر الفائده
وانخفاض قيمه العمله المحليه وايضا على
صعيد الصناعات الدفاعيه والتسليح اذ زادت
تركيا صادراتها من الاسلحه بنسبه 30% بين
عامي 2016
اضافه الى النجاح الذي حققته في مجال
صناعه السيارات بعد ان ضمت الى الشركات
المحليه نحو 13 شركه عالميه لعلامات
تجاريه كبرى الى جانب اطلاقها اول سياره
كهربائيه من انتاجها عام 2017 عقد الحزب
تحالفا مع حزب الحركه القوميه ونجح في
تحويل البلاد من النظام البرلماني الى
الرئاسي عقب استفتاء في تعديل دستوري حظي
بتاييد الاغلبيه فنجم عنه تولي الرئيس
اردوغان ولايه ثانيه اذ فاز في يونيو
حزيران من عام 2018 بمنصب رئاسه الجمهوريه
بنسبه 52% بعد ان الحق هزيمه بخصمه محرم
انجه مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض ورغم الفوز
الاخير تراجعت شعبيه الحزب في العام
التالي فخسر بلديات ولايات مهمه مثل
اسطنبول وانقره بعض الولايات الاخرى
الكبرى وذلك على الرغم من فوزه في النتيجه
العامه على مستوى البلاد وحصده
44.33
من اجمالي اصوات الناخبين في منتصف اذار
مارس 2023 اعلنت الكتله النيابيه لحزب
العداله والتنميه تقديم الرئيس اردوغان
مرشحا للحزب في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقرره في الرابعه عشر من ايار مايو
[موسيقى]